three people on earth have it way worse
than you
billions
lived in a studio apartment the size of
this stage with multiple family members
there are almost two billion people on
Earth that don't have access to clean
water we lack gratitude I have
perspective I'm grateful for everything
I have there are over a billion people
on Earth that don't have access to clean
water and you're complaining that your
Instagram's not growing you
thank you
[Music]
if you're pumped with your life
and you're good and you're not
complaining do you like don't work at
all I don't give a
if you're complaining about your life
you need to look at what you're doing
this message is for the people like oh
I'm not happy I can't find my passion my
shit's not working I'm not lucky I don't
like my job I don't have time I'm
unhappy but people would rather complain
than the work
where are you going like seriously
though people lack perspective if you're
not pumped right now if you're
begrudging what you're about to do if
you're if you're not looking forward to
it what if I told you this was the last
Monday morning in your life what if I
told you to die this week would you
complain about your crap job or that
test you don't want to take I doubt it
you need to understand it it's your
fault
it's not everything in life is on you
stop telling everybody in the world to
do you do
you do she should the government should
my boss should
my husband should my kids should my
teacher should my boss should like
everyone should what about you what are
you doing
the internet being created way more
opportunity for all of us the internet
doesn't give a where you came from
doesn't care about your ZIP code
it doesn't care about anything if
anybody looks like you that did it then
you can too why'd they do it why they
get out you know zero people that are
successful that don't work their face
off
[Music]
take a step back right now and think
about who we all admire they're all
people that punted the system they're
people that practice singing since they
were five there are people that shot 10
000 basketballs every morning it's
always that anything meaningful and good
takes real time and effort you have to
work for it please recognize the world
we're living in the world is abundant if
you're good enough you can get yours too
how do I feel motivated I'm grateful I'm
gratitude somebody's always got it worse
one life do something about it
the second you genuinely stop blaming
anything is the second you start getting
happy I desperately need you guys to
leave here understanding how
ridiculously lucky we are to be alive
during this era
just perspective man it's just
perspective
like there are
repeating this glass is empty
[Music]
there are literally people who think
yeah I mean look you might not even be
alive like your mom and Dad could have
had sex like three minutes later and you
wouldn't even exist we have to become
more optimistic and positive you know
why you're deciding what life actually
is
it is your subjective call here's where
I'm at
400 trillionth one I can't wrap my head
around the fact that it's basically
impossible to become a human being
there's nothing you'll ever accomplish
that's more remarkable than that you
have a chance to accomplish something
[Music]
once you've won the ultimate Lottery
like what are you doing about it because
way too many people in this room are
dwelling about yesterday
that shit's over and you're gonna be
dead forever and you're gonna regret it
please take a step back and think about
how awesome it actually is
foreign
we're being kind too please take a step
back
we're being nice about it
that comma is Big please comma
[Music]
that's why I told you eight years from
now
with Snoop Dogg
no
no I'm gonna go from Top
[Applause]